your amazing project um right now first
of all you're directing your own movie i
am yeah yeah i'm about to we're about to
announce it uh after because we have a
film at sundance right now with uh your
old friend aubry plaza and i we have a
wild relationship from that one wild
yeah there's a wild movie will you come
back and talk about that is emily the
criminal yeah yeah she would love we
just spoke a minute ago yeah it's doing
really really well we're really excited
it's an incredible vehicle for her she
produced it she called me and i was like
yes of course uh and we
we did it and that was a real genesis
for me being like now's the time so yeah
after i go i'll go right from here to
finish another project and then i'll get
into like you know uh pre-pro on this
film that we're going to direct and
produce
and i'm going to star and yeah please
just come back for like everything you
do your recent project
you just have to come back
and
tell us about the kevin hart project um
it's so interesting and not what you
think it is no it's a real curveball
true story yeah super dark on netflix on
netflix and it's just me kevin wesley
and uh wesley snipes leslie snipes my
buddy will catlett who's absolutely
incredible in it tawny newsome uh paul
adelston and it's the creator of narcos
oh wow yeah yeah i didn't know that yeah
creative narcos him and kevin uh uh they
were the genesis of the project and uh
it's wild it's like nothing i've ever
done before it's really not what you
think it is and it's definitely like
watch list check this out it's so cool
and so it's heartbreaking
um heartbreaker well so are you in all
the right ways
um
i am glad that you're back from austin
um how long are you in town i leave in a
couple of minutes
well is there anything you have to grab
when you come here you're like i'm back
home
adjacent well if i was gonna make my way
to staten island which i'm not going to
it would be dinos pizza the reason i'm
not going to is even though staten
island's only a few miles away it takes
about 16 hours guys
it's a different world and it takes but
once pete and colin have the uh
fairy the party party fairy yeah then
i'll then i'll be able to get on there
and uh and do it um but i would go to
dinos i would grab pizza and uh i would
uh sit with my mom and and eat well i
don't know where she was i don't know if
your mom's here but i do have some danny
knows pizza whoa yep that's right
and everybody
this is
[Applause]
thank you so much my first the greatest
better when it's hot
tell us about your amazing pizza thank
you so much for bringing it to us the
best pizza in new york i i'm so selfish
i was like oh good this will make you so
happy is there any extra i am
we brought we brought some nature but
it's better when you eat it there hot
you know we had to travel
six hours to get here
i made it in six i left at six in the
morning but uh we also have we also have
one in manhattan greenwich village and
we're opening in california what yes in
april
oh my god give this to everyone it's the
greatest
yeah it's the greatest oh my gosh
[Applause]
this is some of the best pizza i've ever
had in my life no
i'm going to take that party boat and
come to janina yes
thank you so much for representing
janino's bringing it here everybody run
to staten island and have some dinos and
thank you for supporting and surprising
your friend theo rossi
who's so amazing
thank you so much thank you so much mike
thank you thank you thank you
and theo uh true story is streaming
right now everywhere on netflix and
i'm so proud of you and all of you
[Music]